لأن قبرص أه محمية لأنها
دولة أوروبية فهي ليست
بلدك بالطبع هذا النوع من
عدم اليقين هذا وهذا العداء
وهذا وهذه الاعتداءات لا أعتقد
أنها لمصلحة أي من
الشعب القبرصي أو الأتراك غير
الشرعيين أيضًا  الذين يعيشون في قبرص أو
تركيا يمكن وصف الوضع في قبرص
بأنه متقلب بسبب
الوجود العسكري التركي في الشمال ،
هل تعتقد أن هذا يمكن أن
يعيق جهود بلدك لجذب
الاستثمار الأجنبي
وقد أثبتت قبرص أنها بلد مستقر
حتى
بدون قبرص
يجري حل الحل
بالطبع مع حل السرو
الذي يتم حله ، وأعتقد أن الاحتمال
كان سيكون
أكبر بشكل
كبير وأعتقد أنه كان من
الممكن تحويل قبرص بسهولة لنفترض أن
سويسرا أه الشرق الأوسط
من شرق البحر الأبيض المتوسط
كان ذلك من أجل المنفعة المتبادلة
أه لكل من
القبارصة الأتراك والكوريا واليونانيين في الجزيرة ولكن أيضًا  كان من الممكن
أن يكون للمنفعة المتبادلة أه
أه لتركيا وكل الجيران